ton diplomatique d' emmanuel macron
après la russie hier le président
français est actuellement en ukraine
reçu pour la première fois par un
volodymyr zelensky l'enjeu reste le même
éviter une guerre aux portes de l'europe
on attend de la conférence de presse des
deux hommes avant cela bonjour nicolas
tenzer
merci de répondre à ces quelques
questions vous êtes politologue
professeur à sciences po vous intervenez
souvent donc sur cette crise entre la
russie et l'ukraine emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui étant aidé en ukraine à kiev
avec la volonté de relancer les accords
de paix de minsk accords signés en 2015
entre kiev et moscou après une longue
nuit de négociations on s'en souvient
accords signés partiellement respectée
et par qui avait par moscou
les écouter pour l'instant ils ne sont
pas respectés par moscou c'est
parfaitement clair dans la mesure où il
n'ya pas le véritablement de paix pour
le rappeler l'ukraine est en guerre
depuis huit ans alors sans doute les
accords de mines et scotty il tint à des
dix ont des attaques massives
la part russe ça oui depuis la signature
en 2015 qu en revanche savoir que tous
les ans vous avez un très grand nombre
de soldats d'ukrainiens qui sont occupés
l'année dernière du 21 donc 80 soldats
sont morts vous avez des violations
quotidiennes de ces accords de minsk
donc on ne peut pas dire qu'elles sont
respectées du côté est évidemment un
principe systar ce que cap c'est dans
parti non pas du terrain mais donne plus
d'autonomie aux régions du daim de basse
et quand on sait que ces régions sont
deux fêtes paix par la russie il n'y a
aucune liberté dans ces régions que
toute opposition et réprimer que vous
avez des prisons ils sont enfermés ceux
qui s'opposent de pouvoir on va pas du
tout comment d'élections pourrait
aujourd'hui se tenir et je crois qu'on
en est là aujourd'hui donc ça sera une
impasse puisque emmanuel macron vient
avec cette proposition la relance et les
accords de minsk
c'est à dire que c'est très bien de les
relancer encore fauté il était une des
conditions qui étaient prévus dans ces
accords de minsk 2 c'est le retrait
complet des forces russes évidemment et
notamment pas de l'ensemble des formes
et particulièrement des forces russes et
ça supposait de monsieur
ces régions on passe et le retourne en
quelque sorte dans le giron de kef et
qu'ensuite et puisse y avoir des
élections qui prévoyait plus de 2000
pour ces régions donc est ce qu'on va
pouvoir avancer là dessus emmanuel
macron n'a pas cessé de répéter devant
vladimir poutine et avant il tenait à
l'intégrité territoriale et à la
souveraineté pleine et entière de traîne
cette souveraineté cette intégrité passe
par le départ des portes ce russe il
faudra bien sûr parler aussi de la tri
mais un excès qui ne sont pas évidemment
dans les accords de minsk mais je crois
que concrètement c'est cela ce que ça
veut dire c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
accepter dé facto cette occupation d'une
passe par la russie se poursuivre c'est
là où on en est aujourd'hui malo on ne
voit pas vladimir poutine en tout cas il
n'en donne un signe pas plus d'ailleurs
lors de la conférence de presse commune
hier entre emmanuel macron et vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui ne donne aucun récit
qu'il veuille véritablement appliquer
ces accords
sur sur ce qui s'est passé hier sur la
rencontre poutine macron
emmanuel macron dit qu'il a obtenu un
signal de désescalade
vous êtes beaucoup plus prudent
je suis beaucoup plus prudents parce
qu'on ne sait absolument pas ce que
vladimir poutine ne veut faire donc
encore une fois d'abord en à cette
guerre depuis huit ans à cette invasion
depuis huit ans est ce qu il le sait lui
même ou pas
est-ce qu'il s'est lui-même balle et
demi un footing ce qu'il compte faire
sur l'ukraine alors des personnes ne le
sait ce n'est pas sur les décider mais
il ya quand même plusieurs scénarios
c'est à dire qu'il ya mario était
redouté jusqu'à présent et emmanuel
macron veut éviter à mon avis a raison
dès l'invasion massive at-il de lucre où
il reprendrait en quelque sorte une
forme qu'elle celle qu'on a connue en
2014 2015 donc ça c'est le premier
scénario ensuite et un deuxième scénario
pour aller vite et celui d' attaque
aérienne contre le pen sans troupes au
sol se rend invasion nouvelles ou disons
axe les rations ou amplification de
cette invasion ça c'est la deuxième
scénario troisièmement il ya celui d'une
déco désorganisation de plus en plus
forte de l'ukraine avec des attaques
sporadiques déjà aujourd'hui bien sûr
mais aussi des cyberattaques qui
mettrait en péril la continuité de la
vie des ukrainiens je pense à des cyber
attaques sur les réseaux électriques
d'adduction d'eau
l'ensemble de ce qui permet à
l'administration ukrainienne de
fonctionner et es8 quand il y en a un 4e
mais qui n'est pas le quart natif mais
qui s'accompagne c'est à dire qu'on met
le plus en plus d'éléments russe sous
couvert comme cela s'est vu en 2014 et
2015 est il si son aspect